Let's make our own JavaScript
modules which we can import and
export into each other. I could
make another JavaScript file
alongside app.js but I'm going
to make a new folder called SRC.
That's not anything special but
it allows me to keep my modules
in its own folder. I'm going to
create a couple of modules,
we're going to start with very
simple one where we import and
export one function in two
strings. We'll create a new file
and let's call it config.js.
Config.js is a place where I
like to put all of my API keys
and rest endpoints. Rather than
scattering them through the
entire application, I like to
put them in one single file so
that if I ever have to reference
any of the configuration for my
application, I could just go to
config.js. Inside of that let's
take const API key is equal to
ABC123. Let's stop it at that
and say, "How do I get access to
this API key variable when I'm
in another module, when I'm in
another file?" I'm an app.js
here and I want to know, how do
I get access to this config here?
Variables are not global with
modules. Variables are always
scoped either to their function
or their block, or if they're
not scoped to anything they are
scoped to that module. That's
the kind of benefit of having
modules is you have this little
files that are self-contained
and they don't bleed into
anything else. There's no
global variables that sit on
window for you to be able to
access everything. How do we
actually get API key from app.js?
We need to first of all import
it from app.js, so I'm going to
say import API key from. Now,
this is not a node module, it is
a local file, so we start it
with a relative path./src/config.
Notice how we don't have the .js
on there. It's not necessary. If
I were to try and console.log
the API key, give that a save,
you see that our bundler.js
refreshes. I'm going to open the
index in our browser. You see
on line five where we tried to
console.log API key you do not
see anything. It's an empty
object that has not been
imported. That's because config.
js has not yet exported itself.
In order to make this API key
available outside of this module,
we need to export it. There are
two types of exporting in the
ES6. There is something called
the default export which will
allow you to export it as the
default, which means that when
you import it you can import it
as any name that you like. Then
we also have what's called named
exports, which when you export
it you export it as that
variable name. When someone
imports it on the other end they
must know the name of the thing
that they are importing.
Generally, a default export is
made the main thing that that
module does, if there's anything
the main thing that the module
does. A named export is used for
methods, and variables, and
things that you need to pluck
off from that. I'm going to
show you the default export
first, and then we'll change
this one over to a named export.
To make this API key exported as
default, we go to the bottom
here and we say export default
API key. That is going to be
available outside. Go into appjs
and then we import it. We
already did, import API key from
source config. We can go back to
our JavaScript here and
refresh, and now we see ABC123.
The important part is because we
exported it as a default, we can
name it any possible thing that
we want right here. We've called
it API key because it's the same
thing, but I could name is '"Wes
is cool" as well, and refresh.
It still works exactly the same
way. How come? Because the
default export gets renamed as
whatever you import it as. So
we've imported it as "Wes is
cool" from there. Every module
that you have can only ever have
one default export. However, you
can have multiple named exports
from a module. Let's take this
API key and change it over to
being a named export. The way we
do that is let's just remove
this entirely, and we stick in
export right in front of it.
What that will do is it will
export this variable, or the
function, or the string, or
whatever it is you'd like to
export from the module and
export it is as the name. When I
say this, Webpack is going to
get a little bit angry at me,
because we have a bit of an
error now. It says, export
default imported as "Wes is cool"
was not found. Now, if we go
back here we called it "Wes is
cool," but because we did it as
a named export -- let's put a
little comment, named export --
you have to import it as
whatever it was exported as. We
have to go back here, we can't
use whatever we want. We have to
use API key and then that's
still not going to be enough,
Webpack's going to give us an
error here. It says, "Export
default imported as API key was
not found." What happens is
this syntax imports something
from something that is used for
when something was exported as a
default. If you wish to import a...
What kind of import is this,
it's a named export. If you want
to import something that is a
named export, you simply stick
some curly brackets around it.
It looks kind of like
destructuring, but it's not.
This is just a syntax for
importing things that were named
export from a file. Then if I
gave that a save, Webpack should
finally be happy with us, there
we go. We go back here and
refresh, we get ABC123. Let's
do it again. Go back to config,
let's create a variable called
url and send it to wesbos.com.
How do I get that available to
this other file? Let's take an
export in front of it and you
head back to here. We simply
just import URL, then we have
that URL variable available to
us anywhere inside of this file.
You see how you just pick and
choose the things that you want.
At first that might seem like a
little bit of a pain because you
don't have access to everything,
but that really helps enforced
these small modules that do one
thing and one thing well. If
you make this self-contained
modules, chances are you'd be
able to use them on multiple
projects, and you can just trade
them around and they're easily
testable, and all kinds of other
benefits that we have there.
Here, I've just been exporting
variables but you can also
export functions. Let's say I
have a function called "Say hi,"
and it takes in someone's name
and it console.logs, hello there,
name. If I want that to be
available -- and that could very
well just be an internal
function that I use inside of
this module. They don't all
have to be exported, but if for
whatever reason I wanted it
available in another module. I
would have to stick an export on
it. That would be exported as "
Say hi." Then I can go back into
my import, import "Say hi," and
then I can say, "Hi, Wes." Give
that a save and a refresh here.
It says, "Hello there Wes."
There's all kinds of really nice
syntax for ES6 modules and I
encourage you to search for
export MDN and take a look at
the Mozilla developer network
docs for export. What we've been
doing is we have been exporting
something like this, export
variable, export expression,
export function. You can export
multiple things at once. If we
had a bunch of variable names
const-age = 100 and const-dog =
snickers. I could export both of
those at once, I would say
export, open curly brackets, age
and dog. Then I will be able to
import those into just like I
was doing it here, age and dog.
I'm not going to console.log
them. You'll just have to
believe me that I actually can
use them like that. There's
also a couple of other things
where you can rename them using
the "'as" key word. That's
really important because imagine
you had a variable called url,
or imagine you already had a
variable called API key, you
needed to rename it. What you
can do is you can say import API
key "as" key and it's going to
take the named export of API key
and import it "as" variable key.
It's no longer API key. You can
see my ESLint is saying that is
not defined, why? Because we
imported the API key "as" key
and we have it there, so that's
how we would have to change that
one. The same goes for when you
export things, you can export
age as old. Then when you import
age it's no longer being able to
import it. You have to import it
as old not as age. You have
some flexibility there. If you'd
like to rename them you can also
put this on their own lines just
for readability sake. You do
something like this.
That can be really
handy when you're importing
maybe five or six different
methods from it. That's just a
personal preference as to how
you like to write your code.